But,
uh,
so is a super random,
who's the best podcast you've ever had?
Every time I think I have the best podcasts.
We'll have another one that's better.
I talked to someone that I respect recently and they said that the Elan Musk one
was the best podcast ever.
It's pretty damn good in history.
Yeah.
That one was rather best podcasts in history.
That's a strong word.
That's podcasts ever been made?
Well,
he's such a unique mind.
I mean he just,
they just,
he just posted a video of one of the boring tunnels first,
uh,
completed tunnels.
And so the,
let's see,
agile.
Yeah,
it's an insanely long tunnel through La and they,
they've been doing this only for a few months,
but apparently in December they're going to start doing this.
Like look how long this is.
This is inside La.
I mean this is at his actual completed real tunnel that's underneath la right
now.
Kay.
Can we talk about how there's no like,
like,
like a prototype that we heard about is like,
all of a sudden it was just like,
how do you get a,
who owns the land underneath?
That's a real good question.
I,
I don't think he understood what I was asking when I asked him that.
I'm like,
how do you,
how do you do this?
Like who do you ask to do this?
Like all of a sudden he's called my project manager.
I'm like,
no,
but they started seeing shit under someone's house.
Yeah.
Like what does or has decided to make a law.
Well and they want to dig under their house to make a well and they go through
the roof of your tunnel.
Are they allowed to,
I love that there's humans like him that are thinking on such a massive scale
that are trying to fix the biggest problems that humans are facing that got tons
of dough.
You guys like you were out there riding waves and I'm telling Dick Jokes.
This guys digging holes under the earth.
Yeah.
I mean he's also sending cars in space.
Right?
He sent his own car.
He shot into space.
He's got space ex.
He's talking about colonizing Mars.
He's got a Tesla company that makes the best electric cars on the planet earth.
I mean,
he's got so many different things going on simultaneously.
I just don't understand his capacity for work.
He's trying to,
he's trying to fix the energy,
you know,
the energy problem with,
getting energy from,
from the sun to power your house to power your car,
power cities.
And you know,
I'm like,
it's crazy.
He makes solar panels now that are actually tiles for your roof,
for your house,
a solar roof credible.
Like you replaced the tiles on your roof with these solar tiles.
Solar.